he is the youngest of the wot brothers
he just turned 25 TJ wad of the Steelers
joining us on the program and just got
out of the weight room we wanted to go
around the room and guess what your max
bench is okay TJ one rep okay okay
Paulie I'll start with you TJ watts max
benchpress one rep all time are
currently I'm gonna go for 40 Dan I
think I may be a little low before 40
all right
Fritzie for 65 all right McLovin
ahead 390 all right I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna I'm gonna go 405 TJ
that's more realistic Dan I think the
guys think they're talking to Jay Dan
push tough it is
yeah horrifies right right right
direction which what brother wears the
tighter shirts a while and now okay
that's Derek I think Derek is Rakesh
medium really do dig it for a while got
in that phase where you like to like hem
the arms now how much conversation
communication do the brothers have in
the course of a week every day I mean I
just played Xbox of data for like two
hours last night and we have a group
chat that we were texting a me Derek
he's always sending pictures of his baby
mine and Jays nephew and worry the
FaceTime at texting or calling at least
once a day so we talk all the time but
can you compare opponents do you guys do
that I think JJ and I can more than
Derek and I could be able to position
and engage in our both scouting offenses
and he plays on the left side I play on
the left side as well so I'm just
breaking out right tackles and I'm all
offenses and what they like to do I
think JJ and I can definitely do that
more than Derek and I could how much
does it matter if you're on the right
side or left side with what you do I
think it's a personal preference for me
the left side is just way more
comfortable I feel way more natural from
the left side and I think a lot more the
team's roll out too
my left their right just because of the
quarterbacks I'm mostly right-handed and
I just knowing that quarterbacks can
typically see when you're rushing to
passes she has to be more savvy as
opposed to breaking down and being able
to tackle on I had Edie read on last
hour we were talking about would you
rather face a pocket quarterback or
somebody who can extend to play what
would you rather face
1 million percent of pocket quarterback
I mean he's Ryan quarterbacks are making
was very difficult for guys the Resta
passer it's very tough we face Lamar
Jackson earlier this year and comet ops
just to be able to have discipline rush
lanes and especially if you're playing
man covered behind it because as soon as
the quarterback sees the DBS turn their
backs he takes off and it's tough to
corral them yeah but that's one of those
where you see somebody on film well ok
the last time you saw a quarterback on
film and then you saw him in person and
it was a big difference was who that you
watch somebody on film and then you see
them in person and it's a big different
like what's the biggest difference
you've seen in a quarterback that from
seeing them on tape but then you see
them in person whether its size its
speed its arm strength yeah I think I
mean each and every week is that way the
NFL every quarterback that you see in
person is kind of a wild factor as
opposed to seeing them on film I mean
you talked about Lamar Jackson the guy
on film is doing remarkable stuff and if
the film can't really tell the full
story as opposed to how hard he's
cutting and how fast he's moving in the
acceleration that was definitely a lot
different person and it was on filming
now even this past week against the
Colts I think Jacoby Brissette you see a
lot of guys missing tackles on them and
you really wonder what's happening and
then you see a Gallaudet in person and
even I missed a tackle on them and you
see it is six-five I mean 230 pounds
just a really sturdy quarterback and I
think each and every week you're kind of
surprised at what you see in person as
opposed to the film where were you when
Vin eteri missed that kick against the
Colt I was out there I was just trying
to get my hand on the ball any way
possible and blocked a kick but uh some
push it left or pull it left really
early in the kick and was just super
happy to come on it to win yeah well
what is that like when you know that the
game is on the line and you got a Hall
of Fame kicker and you're just doing
whatever it takes to just get a
fingertip on a football not that you
need
but it's sort of helpless yeah I think
first and foremost we didn't want to
want to jump offsides and give him a
chance to retake it or anything like
that so just trying to get the best jump
on the ball you possibly can get as low
as you possibly can and just try to
stick a hand out there and see if you
can get a hand on the ball but as soon
as you don't do that you turn around as
quickly as possible and see if the ball
is going through the uprights or not
who did you root for growing up I was a
Packer fan for a good chunk of my early
life scintilla JD was on the Texans and
I was the biggest Houston Texas fan for
the past six seven years until I got in
the NFL did you ever meet Favre what was
that did you ever meet Brett Favre I
think I did once at an award show when
JD was when one of his three Defensive
Player of the Year trophy shout all you
J's this JJ did he ever rub it in that
he was collecting all this hardware I
mean that it I think a lot of people
forget that he is he's won three defense
for the Year trophies and it's it's
pretty wild to see how quickly people
forget it's just how the remarkable
stretch he was on I mean I look at his
stats from time to time and just going
back and looking at the amount of
quarterback kids TfL in fact he was
putting out in back-to-back years and
even this this year until he got hurt he
was on pace for the most quarterback
kids of his career and I think people
are very quick to forget stuff like that
you're right you're right and he was
having quietly a great year I think we
look at JJ and then we we got lost with
that but all of a sudden Myles Garrett
is the guy Clos Mack is the guy we
forgot about Von Miller it doesn't take
long for us to forget about you because
we love to move on to what's the next
thing
and I think JJ before he got hurt was
you know maybe fallen victim to that but
then you're getting your opportunity now
because you're newer fresher on the
scene and you're putting up some great
numbers for that Steeler defense and
just just being a team player I'm
putting up as many well I forgot about
the BOCES TJ I didn't okay better
brother combination though better
brother combination though that's the
thing everybody wants to compare and I
think it's alright
to have your own little thing and we
don't always have to compare the watt
brothers versus the bolsa brothers
versus the Gronkowski brothers and all
that stuff I think why can't we all just
be good public and in our respective
ways and I think they're doing a lot of
really good things and I'm just trying
to make as many place I possibly can
help my team win I think I want to go
drinking with the Gronk brothers I'm not
sure who I want in the Octagon though as
far as the brothers like are you guys
crazy like the Gronk's are crazy yeah I
don't think we're I don't think we're
crazy I don't know that's not for me to
bake I'm one of us so I don't know if
I'm crazy or not I'm pretty even-keeled
hey what happened when the beginning of
the year all of a sudden we're going
what the hell happened to the Steelers
so now all of a sudden you guys are
playing what's the biggest difference
here I think we're just taking a game by
game and not trying to look past and
project the future and predict the
future and try to try to figure out what
can happen if and we're just kind of
living in the moment and trying to take
advantage each and every practice and
taking one game at a time and really
respecting our opponents and just trying
to create turnovers I think it's the
biggest thing for us as a defense as
opposed to last year is just being able
to create those turnovers and give the
offense better field position trying to
score any way we possibly can just to
help out our young quarterback what is
it like every day for you to walk around
Pittsburgh given the fact that you know
I mean those are those are fanatics
those are those are that's as good a fan
base as you'll find in any sport yeah
they're big I'm a homebody I don't live
a very fascinating life I stay at home a
lot and they cook at home and but I do
go to the local giant eagle shoutout to
the Pittsburgh people out there and
grocery store and now people always say
great game great game and the good luck
this week I hope you're healthy and
they're they're always very genuine and
sweet and kind to me and I couldn't be
happier to be in this community Congrats
on the season so far TJ we appreciate
your time our best to your brother thank
you guys it's a TJ want Steelers
linebacker
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]